hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
know it's been a long time since I've
played this and admittedly on the last
episode that I did I didn't even know if
I would be playing it again because it
left on kind of a final note getting to
the deepest point that was currently in
the game now this is a brand new game
that I'm starting and I don't intend to
skip forward in it because it's been
about five months then since I last
played and what's really interesting
about the game is that it's been updated
a lot as was expected through the
procedural updating one not every few
months if there's a lot of new creatures
a lot new craftable x' and a lot new
things like that but more importantly
than any of that is I want to play this
game in terms of feeling and exploring
the game again when I was doing those
episodes before it felt like I was
showcasing the developer updates which
is kind of not what the game is about
and it's not kind of what I wanted to do
for videos so when I was doing the
previous videos and some of you guys
noticed this it was like the means to
the end the ends to the meet whatever
the phrases I don't even know I'm not
smart enough to know about that but it
was like I was doing things specifically
only to do a specific other thing
without enjoying what subnautica was the
ocean that you're in the wonderful
environments the beautiful horrific
creatures and there are more the the
Reaper Leviathan actually is in the game
now and can shoot fireballs as far as I
know but I've intentionally not looked
into the updates the many many updates
that there have been I have not looked
into them because I want to explore it I
want to find it I want to see it all see
everything about it I want to know
everything about it by finding it
without having it handed to me you know
what I mean I want this to be
exploration for us
and not exploration for the game
whatever is I'm trying to say something
profound there and it's not entirely
working out but anyway let's blast off
the only survivor
a lonely solitude incoming and also they
fix some things about this intro
sequence but I don't think this has
changed very much since last time that I
showed it to you guys other than the
fact that it's super cool and we still
don't know what blew up the ship and
that is a mystery like what caused this
ship to blow up and was it right or
wrong and think oh [ __ ] my face was it
right or wrong in thinking that there
was another ship that came to this
planet before we did like we're
obviously either a scientific
exploration or for a colonization thing
like that's why we're here but I believe
there was some sort of information there
was another ship before us so anyway I
gotta take care of this [ __ ] boo-ki
oh yes all right we're good here
everybody good bye good ok so now that
we're actually in the game I want to
make a few promises to you guys that I'm
legitimately gonna keep this time number
one I'm never gonna cheat again not once
not never not one time ever am i gonna
cheat again because that ruins the
experience of the game the other thing
about this is I am alone I will have no
outside help I'll have no information
other than the information that you guys
give me because I'm still gonna be
reading you guys comments in between
each episode but in the meantime I won't
be able to put names on lockers until
I'm able to build freakin lockers but
they've done a lot of more things a lot
more a lot more they've done a lot more
to improve the beginning experience the
game and by improve I mean make as some
of you know it was a bit easy to get
started in the game you take four
titanium and then do your dang ol thing
and then build a base and then you're
out of here but as far as I know we're
gonna be using this life pod for a good
long time so we better get used to this
bad boy over there and all the wondrous
joys that it brings so we're here and
apparently I can get let out of these
things now but I'm just gonna be
gathering resources for a bit to get
started
okay either I have not paid attention to
the ocean in a while or they've added
some new [ __ ] there well you guys are a
lot more noisy than you used to be hey
can I poke you in your big bubble why do
you sound like you're laughing
that's not okay I'm new to this world I
mean I'm not new but I'm starting out
like a fresh baby oh god damn it just
let me get the [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
creepiest thing I've ever heard in my
goddamn life
why why was that a necessity okay anyway
I need what are you oh I know you are I
think oh cool they got a better
interface for it that's nice
I'm gonna get these Gary fish and how to
cook him up cook cook them all up hey
you air sack
how are you know you run away ooh
bladder fish nice God you know this is
what I this is what I missed about the
game the the experience of just
wandering around the ocean holding on to
Gary as tight as I can so he doesn't get
away from me it just kind of like
experiencing the wonders of this weird
ocean and then venturing out from the
safety of my encampment I almost had you
get stuck it's stuck yeah you get stuck
it's stuck it's stuck it's stuck my
advantage is that you're dumb what I
need right now is food in my belly I'm
gonna do exactly that lever ski-doos how
about a cookie Gary sorry Gary
I'm gonna keep this one Gary in my hand
I don't wanna I don't wanna mess with
this Gary this Gary is my kind of
favorite Gary publish publish blerg okay
I'm good you rest you bladder fish get
to survive for just a little bit longer
because I need to make [ __ ] before I can
kill you oh my god they actually have
textures for things it has been a long
times as I play cuz they fixed up a lot
of stuff I'm gonna make some batteries I
don't know why but I'm gonna do that I
need a scanner I believe okay scanner
and the one thing that I'm definitely
gonna do is I'm gonna go out at night
which is my least favorite thing to do
and you guys his favorite thing to do
because you get to watch me be a little
screaming [ __ ] but this time I want to
I'm gonna make a flashlight because I
don't actually have that yet it's so
good to be starting back from the
beginning but also so terrifying a I'm
not I'm not as like you know well
prepared as I used to be in terms of
what I'm doing here and I don't exactly
know what I'm doing here and probably
gonna die in a lot of horrible ways but
you know what that's okay oh god it's
getting dark already okay so besides
that we're gonna try to do what we need
to do here which is a whole lot I don't
know why this is the creepiest [ __ ] God
if I came out here at night and I heard
laughing I poop my pants good thing I
got the suit that can recycle my [ __ ] oh
boy oh boy oh boy I feel so helpless I
feel so helpless
I think what it is it's like the UH it's
the comparison between this and a horror
game
not exactly but in a horror game you
know how you don't have weapons and
that's kind of the best situation
because you're totally helpless it's
that feeling of isolation of
helplessness Oh music oh oh my god
see this is another thing that I wanted
about the game is like the taking time
to appreciate the environment and taking
time to actually see what's going on and
that's what I was talking about when I
was saying that I was just blasting
through things to get to an objective
which is perfectly fine in normal
circumstances but in my gameplay and
made it so that it was all together less
enjoyable and that's not what I wanted
out of it and now that I'm here at night
in this beautiful admittedly very
beautiful Chloe brilliant underground
it's so cool air bubbles woof-woof in my
face oh I got blood all over me it's
really cool it's really cool it's
terrifying and it's dark now plus really
cool oh geez oh gosh I'm all alone down
here oh I have no friends all my friends
are dead that's another thing to
remember all my friends are dead I'm
kind of down here alone
I don't know that ten seconds of oxygen
remember I mean my character doesn't
know that yet but you know I'm still
pretty dead like pod number five and
whatever the hell that is
that looks bigger than it used to my god
can I get to the top of this bad boy at
least I get a better vantage point of
actually being able to climb on top of
the thing oh that's so cool oh that's so
cool scan that scan it
scanning planet to find out more hello
what the [ __ ] are you oh they finally
replaced the moon so it's not Earth's
moon up there
God they put a lot of stuff in here oh
cool I've never even looked at the logs
before Oh what is that
yeah common scavenger at the base of the
food chain
threat level minimum small enough to be
of no threat even a small organisms
adapt to defeat on the waste products of
the ecosystem used orion themselves and
three legs for high strength and muscles
not harmful at all so there must have
been scouts out here i mean that's where
that's that's what i'm sorry
there's abandoned bases out here and I
know I'm stalling I'm not going out in
the night because
a big baby [ __ ] anyway I need to make
some more tools I need to make a knife
eventually which means that I need
silicone any creepvine seed clusters so
I'll go out and get that in a bit
that'll be the next thing I do and I'm
gonna do that actually right now I'm not
gonna do that in the bed I'm gonna do
that right now cuz I'm a man a manly man
that's me I'm a big strong man huh boy
but I do need to empty my inventory
before I'm able to do that I get a lot
of titanium here shy don't even know
where I'm gonna where the [ __ ] am I
gonna put it
but the [ __ ] am I gonna put it I don't
have any storage good god I don't even
have a builder oh I have nothing I have
nothing nothing
oh don't let it be ten seconds of oxygen
hey hey I hate this I hate this
everything about this is terrible and I
haven't been able to put all my [ __ ]
anywhere because I can't put it in I
can't put it in the Life pod can i maybe
they change that maybe I can put in life
pod I guess I haven't tried so I guess
that's my bad please tell me that's
daylight coming oh it is okay it is it
is we're doing good maybe I can dump it
all here can I please Dow a kid a kid
dumped it here I am [ __ ] storage
container oh thank you
Oh flare water nutrient block yes I
didn't even know that existed oh thank
you I thought I was gonna have to dump
it on the ground oh you're so helpful
oh thank you thank you okay now now I
can actually go it's not night oh [ __ ]
man
god I forget how stressful this goddamn
game is when you're on your own I hate
the ocean so bunch okay so alright so
I've got the maximum number of those
that I can get so I did it ray
okay that better be Sancho but then
again there's been a while it's been
months since I played this so all the
sounds are a little unfamiliar to me so
I'm not 100% sure exactly what I'm doing
here why is that falling down from there
why is it getting dark so quickly
what now god damn it oh [ __ ] god dammit
oh oh oh oh god damn it I'm an idiot oh
no it's so stupid oh hey why is it
getting dark his night here already
that's weird
oh no wait I'm drowning cuz I'm dumb
okay let's try this again and not die
again this time I probably am gonna die
got it see this is another thing that
I'm not used to the reason I died there
is because before I cheated and skipped
ahead and farmed ahead and I had so much
goddamn stuff then I was just able to do
everything that I wanted to do and they
didn't have to worry about [ __ ] air
oh you know oh you creepy [ __ ] whatever
you is creepy [ __ ] I like you until I
get weapons and build big things I don't
like you I don't want to like you and I
don't think I will ever like you so I'm
gonna go back and then remember how much
I don't like you I'm gonna make a knife
oh boy yay I got a knife weapons were
removed from standard survival
blueprints following the massacre on
Abraxas prime as an essential survival
tool for 2.5 million years the knife
remains the only exception sorry about
that what what does that mean 2.5
million years oh they're talking about
all human evolution that is just
fascinating it's fascinating about the
story of this game in the story of the
universe you're in humanity is so far
advanced that it's reasonable to see
there's so far advanced because number
one they're making all of this insane
[ __ ] like this stuff is just being
fabricated with
Lazer's you're making things with lasers
that's incredible by itself but also
humanity as a whole has advanced so far
that things like weapons are completely
removed and everyone is just cool with
that
from standard colonization [ __ ] fins
Oh to tank yes all things that I need
I'm doing great I'm a survivor who's
used to not having [ __ ] like cheat
codes which I don't have anymore okay so
I need table coral sample and then I
need silver and I think I'm good I think
I'm going to be doing pretty good I
don't know if I'm in am i faster is this
is this fir gary am i faster
do I seem faster to you thanks Gary
you're always a help
okay so there's silver down in the death
place you know the death place and
thankfully I've got a little more air
here and there's that emergency stop for
air if I needed well we're just gonna
venture down and we're gonna get the
silver that we need while trying to
avoid death in the shape of that monster
if I find other resources whoa see my
friend hell yes yes yes but still the
mystery remains why did our ship go down
why through standard atmospheric entry
through what can only be standard
procedure for these advanced humans in
everything that they do and all the
technology they have no-one else
survived why did no one survive in this
day and age when they probably have a
bajillion safety protocols whap [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'll fight you [ __ ] what are
you Elsa let's drive a little bit [ __ ]
you what the [ __ ] was that the [ __ ] was
that
what the [ __ ] was there what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] okay
got silver finally so sandstone and
limestone are now definitively different
which is the thing I'm pretty sure what
that was I think it said like primary
directive is to swim towards it so that
thing controlled my mind Oh what are you
what is with the noise is you you what
is it that's a new thing
no is that new I have no idea so many
different things everybody oh man okay
but we got what we needed we did get
what we need
actually we did not get what we need so
I'm okay hey how's it going there buddy
sorry I gotta put you away a bursty
hoppers keeper saharsky I need also stam
board Korbel nice can you rabbit ray hey
rabbit ray come back here where are you
going
I need some more cool cool okay haha
never ski want me to save cuz I haven't
done that yet I'd hate to lose all my
progress that has been hard but not
cheated for I need to make good dive
real all right that's fine don't know
why I need to be pulled back that
quickly oh wait no that'd be great for
when I dove down in that giant hole that
would have been good to be pulled back
from ha ha ha now I can make the habitat
bill ah davu ski this is exactly what I
needed I now have the habitat builder
and I will be able to do what I need to
do to build myself a hole eventually
with time because as I expect it's night
outside of it it's not thank goodness
it's not not yet but it's gonna be night
soon and I'm gonna be wallowing around
in death for ages and ages and ages and
ages but either way welcome to a brand
new beginning in subnautica there's a
lot of ocean to explore and what's even
better is that I'm gonna be continually
exploring without even knowing what's on
the horizon so thank you everybody so
much for watching
let me know what you think and any other
things you'd like to say to me down in
the comments below I will be reading and
ugly in the next episode I will have
Locker
is for with which you two guys to be on
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video sorry what suggest
a quantum detonation has occurred in the
Aurora's drive core the central Dark
Matter reactor will reach a
supercritical state in t-minus ten nine
eight hey people you want to see this
but you do scry your big eyeball right
into the center of the dang thing and as
always i'll see you in the next video
bye